- QUICK UPDATE FROM
THE "I CAN FINISH!" NEWS DESK:
A SURPRISING DEVELOPMENT
IN THE MURDER TRIAL
OF DR. ARMOND.
DR. ARMOND
TOOK THE STAND AND, ONCE AGAIN,
FAILED TO CONVINCE ANYONE
HE ISN'T A MURDERER.
- SHE'S ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL VICTIMS
I'VE EVER SEEN.
- RUTH DIAMOND PHILLIPS ROSE TO
THE DELIVER THE KNOCKOUT BLOW,
BUT THE DISGRACED PROSECUTOR
OVERPLAYED HER HAND.
- I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IF YOU SAW SHANNON AGAIN?
- IS THAT HER ACTUAL DRESS?
- IS SHE WEARING EVIDENCE?
[courtroom murmuring]
- WHERE HAVE THOSE CLOTHES BEEN?
- FIRST, WHAT HAPP--HE WAS--
HE WENT INTO THE ROOM,
AND THE CLOTHES WERE
IN THE ROOM, AND I-I--
- TOOK THEM...
- TO MY HOME TO DO ROLE--
TO STUDY ROLE-PLAY.
AND I HAVEN'T GOT IT DOWN PAT,
WHICH IS WHY SOME OF THIS
WAS RATHER ROUGH,
BUT I FELT THE FEELINGS.
I FELT GOOD ABOUT IT.
- YOU'RE FREE TO GO.
- WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
TO THAT, DANA?
- SHE'S NOT THE ONE ON TRIAL.
ARMOND IS THE MURDERER.
- IT'S REALLY UNFAIR, YOU KNOW,
HOW THIS IS BEING PLAYED.
AND IT'S INTERESTING
HOW IT'S BEING SPUN,
YOU KNOW,
BY A GROUP OF MEN--
- TO SEE DR. ARMOND CELEBRATE
WITH THE LUCKIEST LAWYER
IN THE WORLD, RON FUNCHES,
IS TO BE SICK TO MY STOMACH.
- EVEN THOUGH I WON
ON A MISTRIAL,
I DID NOT MURDER MY WIFE.
[laughter]
FOR THE FIRST TIME, I WASN'T
TELLING ONE OF MY "HIT" JOKES.
- [laughs]
- ♪ IF I CAN DO IT,
ANYONE CAN ♪